ALSO WE ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
JAMES COMEY'S NEW BOOK.
BUT FIRST MY OPENING STATEMENT.
NOW, WHY WOULD YOU BELIEVE A GUY
WITH A HISTORY REPLETE WITH
LIES, DISHONESTY AND
CONTRADICTIONS?
WE'LL FIND OUT TUESDAY WHEN
DISGRACED FBI DIRECTOR JAMES
COMEY'S BOOK, "A HIGHER LOYALTY,
TRUTH, LIES AND LEADERSHIP" HITS
THE STANDS.
TRUTH, LIES AND LEADERSHIP?
REALLY?
TALKS ABOUT AN OXYMORON, YOU ARE
THE ULTIMATE LIAR.
YOU LIED MULTIPLE PEOPLE
INCLUDING CONGRESS UNDER OATH.
AND THAT'S A CRIME.
TRUTH, YOU REFUSED TO FOLLOW THE
LAW CAUSING BOTH REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS TO CALL FOR YOUR HEAD.
AND LEADERSHIP?
YOU VIOLATED THE RULES OF YOUR
OWN AGENCY BY LEAKING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION TO A FRIEND TO
THREECT "NEW YORK TIMES."
YOU WENT ALONG WITH LORETTA
LYNCH'S FALSE NARRATIVE THAT
HILLARY'S CASE WAS A MATTER, NOT
AN INVESTIGATION.
AND GET READY FOR A KNIFE FIGHT
BETWEEN JIM COMEY AND LORETTA
LYNCH ON BOTH THAT AS WELL AS
THAT TARMAC CHARADE.
JIM, YOU REPEATEDLY HAVE PROVEN
YOUR INABILITY TO RUNT FBI IN A
NON-POLITICAL WAY.
YOU STAYED SILENT AS THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" RETRACTED THE STORY
THAT HILLARY CLINTON'S FBI
REVIEW WAS A SECURITY REFERRAL,
NOT CRIMINAL REFERRAL PASS IF
THE FBI IS A SECURITY COMPANY
INSTALLING LOCKS IN PEOPLE'S
HOMES.
YOU TURN THE WELL-RESPECTED
AGENCY INTO A HAVEN OF ORGANIZED
CRIMINAL CONSPIRATORS AT THE TOP
ECHELON.
YOUR BOOK ISN'T ABOUT
LEADERSHIP, IT'S ABOUT BUTT
KISSING.
LIKE WHEN YOU WERE STRUCK BY THE
WAY BARACK OBAMA COULD SEE AND
EVALUATE A VARIETY OF ANGLES AND
COMPLICATED ISSUES, HIS ABILITY
TO CONNECT WITH AN AUDIENCE.
YOU ARE RIGHT, HE'S REALLY
BRIGHT, LIKE WHEN HE BRAGGED
ABOUT TRAVELING TO ALL 57
STATES.
THE GUY IS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
AND HE THINKS THERE ARE 57
STATES?
AND THE PERSON YOU MOST OF
ADMIRED IN GOVERNMENT, JAMES
CLAPPER.
ANOTHER OUTRAGEOUS LIAR WHO
SWORE UNDER OATH BEFORE CONGRESS
THAT THE NSA DOESN'T SURVEIL
AMERICAN, THEN IN AN OBVIOUS
DISPLAY OF LYING SHIFTS HIS EYES
AND BODY AND SAID, WELL, NOT
WITTINGLY.
YOUR BOOK IS AS PETTY,
UNPROFESSIONAL AND ILLEGITIMATE
AS A STORMY DANIELS RESUME.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE SIZE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S HANDS, WHETHER HE
USED TANNING GOGGLES IN A
TANNING BOOTH AND WHETHER HIS
HAIR IS REAL.
FBI AGENTS BEHIND YOUR BACK
CALLED YOU CARDINAL COMEY.
BUT YOU ARE NOT HOLIER THAN
THOU, YOU ARE A POLITE SCALLOP A
TOUGH TO MAKE YOURSELF THE
CENTER OF A MORAL COME PASS.
THE FBI DIRECTOR BROUGHT FROM
THE FBI AGENTS TO MAKE SURE THE
SECRET SERVICE DIDN'T BLOCK YOUR
DRAMATIC ENTRANCE IN JOHN
ASHCROFT'S HOSPITAL BIDSIDE
QULAIMG YOU WERE WILLING TO
RESIGN IF THE SOUTHERN GENERAL
DIDN'T FOLLOW YOUR SUGGESTION.
BUT ENOUGH ABOUT YOU, LET'S READ
THE BOODGES EXCERPTS.
BUT YOU CLAIM THE PRESIDENT
SITTING AT HIS DECEMBER NEXT
OVAL OFFICE WAS A KING SITTING
ON A THRONE.
A KING BECAUSE THERE WAS A BLOCK
OF WOOD BETWEEN YOU AND THE
PRESIDENT.
AND, JIM, DID YOU EVERB APPEAR
BEFORE A JUDGE?
YOU SAY THE PRESIDENT WAS
CONCERNED WHEN YOU PRESENTED HIM
WITH YOUR FAKE DOSSIER ALLEGING
HE HAD PROSTITUTES PEEING ON HIM
IN MOSCOW.
>> HOW CAN YOU SAY IF THERE IS A
1% CHANCE YOUR WIFE WOULD THINK
YOU HAVE PROSTITUTES PEEING ON
YOU.
POLICE A 1% CHANCE MY WIFE WOULD
THINK THAT WAS TRUE.
JUDGE JEANINE: YOUR WIFE WAS
NEVER PRESENTED WITH A FAKE
DOSSIER BY THE DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI WHO PARENT THREATICALLY
NIGHT WASN'T -- WHO KNEW IT
WASN'T TRUE.
YOU KNEW AT THE TIME IT WAS NOT
VERIFIED.
THE WHOLE THING WAS A CHARADE.
AND WHEN YOU WERE ASKED BY
STEPHANOPOULOS.
>> DID HE HAVE THE RIGHT TO KNOW
THAT?
>> THAT IT HAD BEEN FINANCED BY
HIS POLITICAL OPPONENTS?
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT.
JUDGE JEANINE: YOU DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER.
THEN YOU SAY THIS.
>> BUT I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES HAD PROSTITUTES PEEING ON
EACH OTHER IN MOSCOW IN 2013.
IT'S POSSIBLE, BUT I DON'T KNOW.
JUDGE JEANINE: IT'S POSSIBLE,
AND IT'S POSSIBLE MARTIANS WERE
IN THAT ROOM PEEING ON THE
PROSTITUTES, TOO.
MAYBE WE SHOULD START A NEW
INVESTIGATION.
WHEN YOU RIDICULE THE PRESIDENT
ASKING YOU WHETHER HE LOOKED
LIKE A GUY WHO NEED HERE.
YOUR ANSWER?
>> SIR, I'M NOT SAYING WE CREDIT
THIS OR BELIEVE IT.
JUDGE JEANINE: JIM, YOU DON'T
CREDIT, YOU DON'T BELIEVE IT?
AROUND LIAR.
THIS IS THE DOSSIER YOU
PRESENTED TO A FISA COURT JUDGE.
YOU TOLD THE PRESIDENT YOU
COULDN'T CREDIT.
WHEN YOU SAID YOU COULDN'T
BELIEVE IT AND YOU SEEK A
WARRANT FROM THE JUDGE BASED ON
THIS FAKE DOSSIER.
WERE YOU LYING BEFORE THE JUDGE
OR WERE YOU SNRIEGHT BOOK.
WHILE WE ARE AT IT, YOUR
EXPLANATION FOR ANNOUNCING
HILLARY, RENEWS INVESTIGATION,
YOU CLAIM'S BECAUSE YOU TOLD
CONGRESS IF NEW INFORMATION WERE
TO COME TO LIGHT, WOULD YOU HAVE
TOLD THEM.
JIM, YOU COULD HAVE CALLED TWO
MEN INTO A ROOM WITH YOU AND
TOLD THEM.
JIM, LIKE POLITICS DIDN'T ENTER
ANY OF YOUR DECISIONS.
YOU HAVE THE CHUTZPAH TO CLAIM
NONE OF YOUR DECISIONS WERE
BASED ON POLITICS.
BUT IN YOUR OWN BOOK YOU SAY
QUOTE WHEN I THOUGHT SHE WAS
GOING TO WIN, I DIDN'T WANT A
TAINTED PRESIDENT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, JIM?
NEITHER CLAIM IS TRUE.
EVERYONE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT KNOW
YOU REOPENED THE HILLARY CLINTON
CASE BECAUSE THE NYPD AND THE
FBI FIELD OFFICE WERE GOING TO
OUT YOU FOR PROTECTING HER AGAIN
BY NOT REOPENING THE CASE.
THE ULTIMATE PROOF YOU DIDN'T
WANT TO INDICT HER WASN'T JUST
THE EXONERATION MEMO.
BUT KNOW SHOWING HAD CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION ON YOUR EMAILS YOU
SWORE UNDER OATH WAS TRUE.
NOW ASKING HER THIS QUESTION,
HILLARY, DID YOU HAVE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION ON YOUR EMAILS
THAT'S A CRIME.
IF SHE SAID NO,
IF SHE SAID NO -- SHE LIED AND
THAT'S A CLIMB.
THE BOSS TOMORROW BOMB, THE
FORTHOOD MASSACRE, THE ORLANDO
PULSE NIGHTCLUB SHOOTING, THE
SAN BERNARDINO MASSACRE, THE
ATTACKS OF 9/11, YOU WERE
INVOLVED IN ALL OF THEM.
YOURSELF-SERVING STATEMENTS
ABOUT A CRYING CHUCK SCHUMER
THANKING YOU FOR YOUR HILLARY
DECISION AND YOU ON THE VERGE OF
TEARS AFTER OBAMA TOLD YOU HOW
GREAT YOU ARE.
COME ON, YOUR CIVIL IN ABSORBED
MEMOIR IS ALL ABOUT YOU.
YOU ARE A POMPOUS, EGOTISTICAL
CONDESCENDING HOLIER THAN THOU
OPERATIVE CASHING IN ON LIES.
YOUR BOOK IS ABOUT A HIGHER
LOYALTY TO NONE OTHER THAN YOU